vamos a regresar a nuestro ejemplo bien
sencillito y bien facilito de un banco y
ver si podemos utilizarlo para entender
o al menos obtener una mejor idea de qué
es el dinero y cómo se crea entonces en
el ejemplo original dije déjame verlo
voy a escribir por aquí y dije tengo
esta idea hay un montón de granjeros que
al final de la temporada venden todas
sus manzanas y supongamos que eso de ahí
es el mayor ingreso de efectivo en
nuestra aldea y luego cada año
ellos juntan su dinero verdad tienen no
sé en total pues mil piezas de oro mil
piezas de oro al menos este año vamos a
ponerle por aquí mil de oro tienen mil
piezas de oro y normalmente los
granjeros los guardan en su cama o no se
hacen un hoyo y lo guardan ahí lo que
sea y yo digo pues qué desperdicio
realmente hay emprendedores con
buenísimos proyectos no sé canales
fábricas lo que sea cualquier cosa pero
simplemente ellos no tienen el dinero
para construir esas cosas si de alguna
forma pudieran obtener este dinero y
usarlo para esos proyectos en todo
de hecho crearíamos riqueza tendríamos
innovación y nuestra aldea se
desarrollaría muchísimo entonces lo que
voy a hacer es lo siguiente voy a
empezar un banco voy a hacerlo como lo
hice en el vídeo pasado entonces
supongamos que invertía así inicialmente
yo solito mil piezas de oro me voy a
quedar ahorita con el oro como moneda
porque quiero mostrarte al crear un
banco de todas formas hay un efecto
multiplicador aunque la moneda sea oro
algunas personas piensan que pasa solo
con papel pero en realidad es un sistema
del sistema bancario de reserva
fraccionario que es lo que hice en el
vídeo pasado pero bueno vamos al ejemplo
tengo esas mil piezas de oro y luego
construir esta bonita bóveda que se ve
súper padre así templo griego todo esto
es un bien raíz o bien un edificio esto
de aquí vale 100 de oro en esta hoja de
aquí a la izquierda voy a poner los
activos y a la derecha los pasivos y el
capital y le digo a cada granjero sabes
que tu dinero no está seguro en tu
granja y de hecho si lo depositas en mi
edificio te voy a dar intereses los
granjeros dicen baja
suena súper padre depositan sus mil
pero en mi banco entonces ahora tengo
este pasivo que consiste en mil piezas
de oro y pues porque es un pasivo porque
se lo debo a los granjeros en algún
momento en el futuro van a venir y van a
decir sabes que el oro que te di lo
necesito entonces es un pasivo para mí
pero también se vuelve un activo para mí
porque todo el negocio consiste en poner
este dinero a trabajar entonces voy a
poner tantito apartado voy a hacer unas
reservas verdad voy a hacer las reservas
en rojo luego vamos a prestarles más
atención y digamos que voy a poner 10%
aparte y entonces pongo 100 piezas de
oro aparte va entonces hago eso en caso
de que alguno de los granjeros el
siguiente día o la siguiente semana
venga y diga sabes que necesito un poco
de dinero necesito dinero porque mi hijo
necesita cortarse el pelo o lo que sea
no importa de cualquier forma yo pongo
100 monedas de oro como reservas y el
resto los los 900 que quedan las 900
piezas que quedan las voy a prestar
déjame ponerse en otro color en verde
esas 900 piezas de oro las prestó
entonces es un activo pero él
ya se fue verdad el oro ya lo presté
tenía mil piezas de oro me quedé con
cien de ellas y luego el resto
novecientas se las voy a prestar a
alguien que tenga un muy buen proyecto
normalmente van a ser muchas personas
pero ahorita por simplicidad se lo voy a
prestar a una persona que tiene un
proyecto de pues canales de irrigación
entonces va a tomar esas 900 piezas de
oro le va a pagar a personas para que
construyan su canal de irrigación a
personas que ya no tienen nada que hacer
y ellos lo que van a hacer es construir
el canal de irrigación de modo que haya
más terreno para plantar más manzanas el
siguiente año digo pues eso suena muy
bien suena que al siguiente año va a
haber más manzanas y le van a vender
agua a los granjeros segurito me van a
poder pagar y con interés para entonces
les presto 900 900 piezas de oro para
construir estos canales y pues ya que
tienen esas 900 piezas esas se las pagan
a los trabajadores verdad o sea los
toman prestados con eso le pagan a los
trabajadores entonces el oro va a los
trabajadores y cuando el proyecto se
termina ahora tienes un montón de
trabajadores que
tienen 900 piezas de oro pesos
trabajadores pues no son nada tontos
verdad justo como los granjeros dicen
sabes que yo no quiero guardar en el
colchón ni meterlo al jardín quiero que
tengan interés y que estén seguros
entonces supongamos que mi banco sigue
siendo el único banco de la ciudad
vienen conmigo y me dicen sabes qué
banco de sal quiero depositar mi dinero
contigo y yo digo va súper padre
entonces voy a tomar tus 900 piezas
bueno sus 900 piezas de oro como
depósito
aquí 900 piezas como depósito tomo sus
a ver si estoy acá son 1900 baja
entonces son 900 piezas de oro va esto
de aquí es el depósito de los granjeros
del dinero inicial luego obtuve otras
900 piezas de oro de los trabajadores
ahora quiero hacer esto lo más bonito
posible pero no quiero tener varios
bancos porque esto se puede hacer con un
banco a lo mejor en el futuro hable de
de varios bancos para que veas que todos
los depósitos no tienen por qué ir a un
mismo lado pero es la misma idea como
sea estás 900 piezas de oro otra vez las
depositan en mi banco para que las
guardias y yo digo la verdad yo no
necesito guardar todas estas 900 piezas
de oro porque pues no necesito tanta
reserva voy a volver a prestarlo para
algunos otros proyectos útiles entonces
una vez más digo sabes qué objetos de
acá son depósitos reclamables es decir
los granjeros pueden venir y pedirlo
entonces voy a poner un poquito al lago
otra vez y pues no sé pensando que que
no más del 10% van a venir por ello
entonces déjame apartar otra vez el 10%
voy a poner 10 por ciento de éstos
serían 90 piezas de oro
pongo aparte 90 piezas de oro y luego
u otras voy a poner eso en el color de
préstamo las otras las otras piezas de
oro las otras cuentas son 810 810 piezas
de oro las presto supongamos que ahora
se las presta aún a un emprendedor y tal
vez no estamos pelando el interés el
interés va a ser después pero ahorita
eso se lo prestamos se lo prestó yo a un
a un emprendedor que quiere construir
una fábrica una fábrica de no ser
herramientas para cortar eso nos va a
ayudar a todos para ser más productivos
cortando manzanas o tal vez vivir
cavando canales lo que sea va a
construir una fábrica entonces construye
una fábrica una vez más estos estas 810
piezas de oro van a ir a los
trabajadores que construyen palos a los
obreros vamos a llamarle pues a los
albañiles vamos a ponerle que van a los
albañiles de la fábrica van a ser las
personas que construyeron la fábrica los
albañiles pero una vez más ahora ellos
tienen 810 piezas de oro no quieren
guardarlas en su casa sal tiene una
bóveda súper bonita
y de interés entonces toman esas 810
piezas van y la depositan en mi banco
las deposita en todas esas entonces esas
810 piezas las depositan en mi banco ok
y luego yo podría seguir haciendo esto
verdad o sea es la misma idea lo podría
volver a prestar y lo que sea pero por
el momento no lo voy a seguir haciendo
claro esto no va a poder seguir hasta
infinito porque cada vez tengo menos
después vamos a hacer matemáticas
sofisticadas para ver cuántos pasos
podemos hacer pero supongamos que aquí
nos detenemos ya sabes como por brevedad
y por cuestiones de espacio pero bueno
esas 810 piezas me las traen yo siento
que ya preste mucho dinero no quiero
correr tantos riesgos y me quedo con las
810 piezas como reserva
entonces las estas 800 ya no las presto
podría podría dejar 10 por ciento
apartado y luego puedes prestar el resto
pero no lo voy a hacer simplemente me
voy a quedar con las 810 piezas como
reservas entonces esta es mi hoja de
balance después de que sucedieran todas
esas transacciones y ahora la hoja de
balance se va a ver así estos son mis
activos estos son mis pasivos y observa
se sigue cumpliendo que los activos son
los pasivos más el capital por acá
tenemos el capital capital acá arriba
son pasivos brazos depósitos que le debo
a las personas son depósitos que son
activos pasivos son activos para la
gente para el banco son pasivos y estos
de acá son mis activos un poco de esto
es dinero en efectivo verdad en color
rosa mexicano estos 800 10 90 a 100
todas estas son monedas de oro
definitivamente son activos que tengo si
los otros son préstamos este y este son
préstamos que se los di a alguien y eso
es un activo 100
cuando siempre y cuando me paguen de
regreso ahora ya con todo esto planteado
mi pregunta es la siguiente cuánto
dinero hay en el sistema cuánto dinero
hay en nuestra economía bueno pues esto
depende de cómo definamos dinero vamos a
hacer una definición vamos a suponer que
voy a definir una definición de dinero
que se llama m 0 y esto simplemente es
cuánto oro hay en el sistema cuánto oro
hay en el sistema pues va vamos a
contarlo observa todo el oro hasta
ahorita lo he guardado yo en mi banco
entonces simplemente hay que ir a mi
banco y contar a ver que hay sienta que
hay 90 ya que hay 810 los 810 más 90 más
100 es igual a mil piezas de oro
entonces hay mil piezas de oro en moneda
m cero y esto de aquí tiene sentido
porque pues porque empezamos con mil
piezas de oro no nos sacamos de minas
nada de oro nuevo y no hay ningún truco
no utilizamos la piedra filosofal para
hacer más
tampoco se destruyó empezamos con mil
piezas de oro y no hay forma de crear
más
y que se destruyera entonces pues
todavía debemos tener mil piezas de oro
entonces esta es la definición así más
fruta para el dinero que está en el
sistema vamos a otra definición vamos a
llamarle m15 que se me está acabando el
tiempo m 1 esto de aquí es cuánto dinero
las personas creen que tienen en
términos de sus cuentas de cheques ajá
cuentas de cheques pues a ver los
granjeros piensan que tienen mil piezas
los constructores del canal piensan que
tienen 900 y los albañiles de la fábrica
piensan que tienen 810 si los sumamos
son mil más 900 más 810 es saber mil 900
más esto cuánto es dos mil 710 si dos
mil 710 piezas de oro entonces si
hicieras una encuesta y vas preguntando
por la ciudad hey tú cuánto tienes en tu
cuenta de cheques o hay cuánto puedes ir
y reclamarle al banco
si hicieras esa encuesta y sumas todo te
daría en total dos mil setecientos diez
piezas de oro si sume bien pero creo que
si estoy aquí es el efecto multiplicador
y esto ocurre siempre que tienes un
sistema bancario de reserva fraccionaria
a esto es a lo que la gente se refiere
cuando habla este de que el aval de que
el dinero se multiplica es lo que lo que
pues como que en el fondo quiere decir
que la que el dinero se cree habíamos
empezado con mil pero por este efecto
multiplicador la gente piensa que hay
dos mil setecientos diez piezas de oro
en el país va en el siguiente vídeo voy
a ver qué tan correcto es pensar que
haya esta cantidad de dinero nos vemos